- [Bart] Hello.
- Hey.
- [Bart] I'm Bart, I practiced
my question so many times
that I lost my voice.
(audience laughter)
- That's amazing.
- [Bart] First of all, I would
like to thank you because
I started my career
as an entrepreneur by
trying to build
the next Facebook.
But thanks to your
speeches on self-awareness,
I came to realize that I
lose sleep over borrowing
a hundred euros from my
brother so I probably will
never build the next Facebook.
Having that in mind.
So, a year ago,
I started to build a data
migration company, organically.
So, I landed a
big customer, and now
I get paid every day,
and I'm developing my stuff.
And we went live in
production in Chile,
in December.
This year for the
same company we will do
USA, Mexico and Canada.
So it's growing really great.
But my question to you was,
you talk a lot about patience,
but you also talk
sometimes about speed.
And patience
for me that would be
continue with the same--
- Can I answer you
real fast and you'll
understand it forever?
- [Bart] Okay.
- Macro, patience. Micro, speed.
- [Bart] Yeah. Okay.
- And let me expand on it,
'cause that didn't work.
Fuck.
(audience laughter)
No no, hold on, hold on,
hold on, back back back.
Macro patience.
You're a young man.
Building something
meaningful, a relationship,
a business,
it takes 10, 20, 30 years.
On your day-to-day work,
you have to be fast.
With the clients, they email
you, you email them back.
Like, your day-to-day.
But your vision?
What you want
to achieve in life?
You're not going to
build it in one year.
And so many
people have it reversed.
In the day-to-day, they're slow,
and in the macro, they
want their business to be huge
the next day.
So you need to reverse it.
- [Bart] So if you have to
make the decision between,
in my case,
building a better framework
or focusing on that, or
trying to find more customers,
what would you advise?
Knowing that I don't need
the money of new customers
right now.
- Both.
- [Bart] Okay.
(audience laughter)
- And so here's another,
here's an answer of both:
Number one, how
hard are you working?
I don't know.
If you're
working 12 hours a day,
I feel like you could
work 17 if you want! Right?
Number two, if
you're working every hour,
and you can't work more,
with the money that's coming in,
too many young people
and too many young businesses
when they start
having money come in,
take it for themselves.
They want to buy a good watch.
They want to buy a good car.
They want to buy fancier shoes.
What I would do is,
when my first money,
so here's my story.
This is not advice
I'm giving just for fun.
This is my life.
I walked in my dad's store,
it did $3 million a year,
10 percent gross profit,
$300,000 dollars in profit
before expenses,
we had no money,
I was making $40,000 a year,
37,4, actually.
And I built that
business from 3 to 45 million,
in the first kind
of four or five years,
and five years later,
five years later this is doing
$45 million dollars in sales,
and I'm making $40,000 dollars.
This is the advice I gave.
And by the way, I was
in my twenties, and a guy.
The exact time, if you're
making that kind of money,
that you want to use it
to do guy things.
Right?
I put it back into the business,
I hired four more managers,
six more managers,
seven more managers,
I did more advertising.
I built a business.
So if this money's coming from
Chile and U.S. and Mexico,
hire people.
Then you can do both.
- [Bart] Okay. Thanks.
- You're welcome.
(hip hop music)